the way I think about it is like our
brains always have this tribalism kind
of um switch that is there ready to be
turned on people don't really want news
necessarily what they want is they want
to watch a reality show an entertaining
addictive reality show with good guys
and bad guys people you hate people you
love especially if it feels like you're
inside of it you know it's my team and
their team in the reality show that will
hook people that will hook people hard
because again this primitive mind is
very into that now the model is you know
can you entertain can you get people
gripped and angry and feeling like you
know they're just hooked on this reality
show and they feel like they're inside
of it themselves and accuracy when that
is going on like just goes out the
window accuracy stops mattering that
they don't get penalized for it and
neutrality forget that it's long gone we
think empathy is great right empathy
what could be bad about that we should
have more empathy but actually empathy
can be used
very you know cleverly to to make to to
breed complete dehumanizing hate
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today is an
author and one of the most popular
bloggers in the world Tim Urban welcome
to trigonometry thanks thanks for having
me Tim listen before we get into the
conversation itself tell us a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us
um yeah I mean I've always uh
I've always been uh someone who is very
curious and likes like learning and
thinking and like framing stuff
um and
uh I've also always liked
um
uh you know like I don't know I would
come back from a trip and I'd write like
a long
um kind of funny email to a group of
friends about what happened so I've
always kind of liked like that form of
writing like like casual
um and um and and in 2005
um I started a Blog on blogger.com
and um realized that this was I hated
writing my whole life because it was
school writing uh so I thought writing
is like you know Humanities that you
know
um but uh I realized that I I like
blogging it's fun and uh I like the kind
of like wild card of like you never know
something's gonna go viral you never
know what people are gonna think it kind
of makes it kind of exciting so it was
an activity I liked and then uh did it
on the side for a bunch of years and
then decided to go serious with it and
go full time um in 2013.
um and that's that's what I've been
doing since so uh Tim one of the things
you've been talking about a lot in
recent years is how our brains are
causing all the tribalism and the
division that we're now seeing out in
the world can you tell us uh a lot about
that because you've got some very
interesting ideas and ways of looking at
it uh about how we've got to where we've
got to
um yeah I mean I I the way I think about
it is like our brains always have this
um this tribalism kind of um switch that
is there ready to be turned on
um you know so our brains haven't
changed but um
but
um something more recently has been
really triggering it like it's uh it's
like you know we always have a craving
for for sugar and fat and um
um and then you can have like a massive
wave of you know fast food restaurants
open and people aren't wise yet to the
fact that they're selling you unhealthy
food and they frame it as healthy and
it's delicious and there's a giant wave
of obesity uh and that that switch was
always there uh they're just a certain
the environment changed and we we didn't
we weren't wise to what was happening
yet and a lot of people kind of fall
into it fall for it and uh end up uh and
and it works and we all end up in a you
know a tribal culture war that uh no one
no one really wants to be in and that is
stupid to be in and that is um
uh doesn't really map on to the you know
zoom out of our time which is that it's
a very prosperous
um time living is about as well as
anyone in history has lived um uh and
with high stakes things going on for the
future you know like you know exploding
technology and all this stuff where the
last thing you'd want is for us to start
descending into like an inane uh culture
War um so
um
so yeah I tried to like dig into what is
what is going on in our brain why are we
why do we have this switch and and uh
the way I kind of um
the way I kind of uh thought to kind of
frame it is there's this this higher
mind uh you could say we have in our
head
um that is
um that just kind of thinks clearly and
and understands that you know uh
um that that kind of Hardcore tribes
aren't really real and that we're just a
bunch of individuals and that
nuances complicated and Truth is hard
and uh that that um that like there's no
clear-cut you know right and wrong and
that has humility about what we know
just the kind of thinking that anyone
would do if they were in their right
mind because it's just based on obvious
reality and then there's this other
character in our brain I call it the
Primitive mind which is the kind that is
just wired for survival in an ancient
world uh and and it's not concerned with
you know it's not good at truth yeah
it's not good at
um it falls for kind of uh cheap tricks
like thinking that you're on this big
tribe and these are the good guys and
they're perfectly good and they're right
about everything and those are the bad
guys and they're wrong and everything
that's the same kind of part of our
brain that would fall for
um you know seeing you know low-fat
Wheat Thins in the store and think oh
that's cow is this healthy and and you
think that it's healthy to eat Skittles
because it tastes delicious and it's
chewy and that part of your brain
doesn't get that this is bad for you
which thinks this must be this is so
delicious it must be a good thing to eat
so it's not a very wise part of our
brain
um but it's totally been tricked and and
and inflamed over the past few decades
By changes and you know the way the
media is this is I'm talking about the
US and probably other parts of the
western world too but
um you know I don't want to speak for
other countries but
um it's you know social media all these
environmental changes have just been an
easy trap for that part of our brain and
uh we're seeing the results of that
and you mentioned social media that's
obviously like the go-to have there been
other things as well I mean you
mentioned uh media more generally and
the 24-hour news cycle I imagine was one
of the big changes that has caused this
uh is there anything else or is it
really just about the way we consume
information now just like you mentioned
McDonald's with food
yeah I mean I saw on Twitter a um a
graph the other day that was saying
something like um you know it was asking
people uh do they think that the
government is generally working for the
people or that it's like devious and
doing awful things and 2002 it was like
50 50 split and then that's just change
and change now almost everyone you know
or three quarters of the country thinks
that the government is out out to you
know doing doing evil awful things
behind everyone's back and that and
there's a lot of these you know that
that you know people's beliefs about
race relations um were steady for a
while and then just plummeted uh
starting in like 2013 and now everyone
thinks that race relations are worse
than ever
um you know
um you know things like these aren't
necessarily all the same thing but like
um people's just Outlook in general
people's feeling like things are unfair
in general people's feeling like
um like the end is near you know the all
of this kind of this thought has is on
the rise but
look at like crime statistics or poverty
statistics or disease statistics you
know it doesn't actually map on um to
the it doesn't make sense it doesn't uh
it's not can't just be a result of well
things are getting much worse and so
people believe that
so um then you're reminded that like we
don't really none of us the reality of a
society the that is you could spend a
million years with perfect data on
everything and still not be able to wrap
your head around what the hell it's so
complicated right so you can't think
that with your depiction of the world is
going to be completely accurate you we
have a uh a picture painted for us
um uh and for many people that's by by
the media
um
and uh if you think about the way the
media used to be
um the news media was there was a half
hour of news a night on three major
networks a half hour so
um you know and local news was always
kind of trashy and like covered like
negative stuff and covered murders and
stuff then the national news was
generally like they just didn't have
time for they had 30 minutes to
be like here's what's happening in like
giant world affairs and like the
national Affairs and
um and then people turned it off and did
something else uh and then what happened
you know with the Advent of cable TV and
then you know first it was CNN which was
kind of neutral for a while
um and it was in the mid 90s that I
think Fox News kind of pioneered a
strategy that then MSNBC picked up on
and then and then and then CNN itself
jumped on that and then a ton of other
you know a lot of a lot of our
newspapers that used to be more
um professional and neutral and of
course million internet websites all
jumped on this this new business model
this genius new business model which is
that uh people don't really want news
necessarily what they want is they want
to watch a reality show an entertaining
addictive reality show with good guys
and bad guys people you hate people you
love especially if it feels like you're
inside of it you know it's my team and
their team in the reality show that will
hook people that will hook people hard
because again this primitive mind is
very into that and so you start having
is instead of news
for 30 minutes a day you now have 24
hours a day of programming that is
essentially a reality show there's 10 or
12 politicians that are the the cast you
know you don't hear about uh most of the
Congress you hear about the cast you
hear about the the you know Matt Gates
and you hear about AOC and you hear
about Trump and you know
um and they're not they're not always
the big decision makers you know the
heads of committees and stuff we often
don't hear about those people we hear
about the the people who have been cast
on the show and
um they frame every issue uh and of
course they're not talking to the whole
country and trying to be neutral they're
they're which they had you know that was
the incentive structure back then you
know if you're not neutral you're going
to get penalized for it if you're biased
and talk to one side of the country it's
not going to work if you're inaccurate
you're going to be a joke you're going
to be laughed at if you're less accurate
than the other and then you know NBC is
less accurate than ABC and CBS now the
model is you know uh can you entertain
can you get people gripped and angry and
feeling like you know you know they're
just hooked on this reality show and
they feel like they're inside of
themselves and accuracy when that is
going on like just goes out the window
accuracy stops mattering that they don't
get penalized for it and neutrality
forget that it's long gone right it's
very clear you're watching a news
network and it's the people in there
speaking to you instead of being you
know famously
uh close to the vest about their
political views like that Ted Koppel or
you know broca or Jennings all those
guys uh now it's of course you know
exactly who all these news anchors voted
for they they're extremely clear about
that so
the point you know now you have 20 so
now you have this thing couched as news
but it's actually 24 7 Entertainment
they have to fill all those time and and
the same reason that local news back
then did the negative thing you know
because that's what's more gripping now
these things are doing that and you know
24 7 and people are hooked on it they
they don't no one you know they people
flip on that as their uh as their uh
entertainment you know it's thing why
would you watch so much news because
it's not really watching news they're
watching their favorite reality shows so
I think that's a factor the changes in
media just like social media these are
these are factors but actually like you
can look and there's there's a lot of
different factors it's hard to actually
pinpoint like one thing that has led us
to this moment
this particular line of discussion Tim
one of the things I'm curious about is I
think what you're saying is obviously
true and at the same time if I switch on
the low part of my brain and I go hold
on a second if I'm on the left I'm
looking out at a world where the last
president of the United States refused
to accept the results of an election his
supporters stormed the capital uh
inequality is rising uh and affecting
millions and millions of people
um and if I'm on the right I'm going
well look they're teaching about anal
sex in schools and their Tran the libs
are transing the kids and I could give
you plenty of example you know Donald
Trump's about to be put in prison and or
whatever right so
I understand your point about you know
crime statistics and whatever would you
not agree though that perhaps maybe
because of the way we have conversations
we actually are ending up in quite a bad
place in reality now
yeah so actually I think
to be more clear I I I think that um
that it's like kind of a little bit of a
meta situation where
initially I think the the beginnings of
these trends of people starting to feel
like everything was awful
I think you can attribute that to stuff
like the media making people believe
that in a way that doesn't represent
reality
but when you do that for years to a
nation and you start to build these
really intense delusional tribes
now the the actual delusional tribes
themselves and and people's fear of them
starts to create actual really bad
problems so I would say that if you
trace you know January 6th back I think
you know you can trace it right to the
Advent of Fox News
um and just to you know to to to put
things like that I think if you trace
the rise of wokeness um and how it's
hijacked so many you know lowercase L
liberal institutions with with their
ideology that's the opposite of liberal
um I think you can look back and I think
you know that that's been around for a
while kind of per you know incubating in
universities that ideology but it
exploded out of the gates I think you
can trace that back to stuff like
Twitter
um and stuff like MSNBC and things like
this
um and so I think it's that these Trends
were Maybe started a little bit
artificially and then they actually
create real problems and then this is
you know I I I'm I'm I I'm far from
saying that that we don't have any real
problems this is all fake now I think I
think partially because of these Trends
the reason I would write about these
Trends if I thought they were just a
bunch of delusion and what okay it's
because they have giant effects actually
they create uh they they they actually
um they create a lot of uh instability
and they they s the power
um in in in the country is you know has
in a lot of cases really swung from kind
of the vast majority of lowercase L
liberal somewhat moderate people two you
know uh kind of Fringe groups that you
usually would be Fringe and you know and
then and then those groups because
people are scared of them can actually
recruit and get a lot bigger and get
more powerful so
um so yeah there's I guess that's that's
just two separate things in a way
oh Tim look I I agree with all with
completely with your analysis on this
and there's also a home a hormonal
element to it which is you know oxytocin
we had a guest on the show a few years
back called Dr Mike Martin and he was
actually explaining to us that the
hormone oxytocin is what creates a group
but it also gives you mistrust of the
other and that's really worrying because
if there's a deep biological aspect to
this then you go how can we solve this
problem
I was just reading a great book um by
Tobias Rose Stockwell and a new book
called The outrage machine and
it's about social media and all that and
he talks about um he talks about this we
think empathy is great right empathy
what could be bad about that we should
have more empathy but actually
uh empathy can be used
very you know cleverly to to make to to
breed
complete dehumanizing hate
um and so you know an example would be
you know think about how many people
uh in the Arab world you know would like
to legitimately genocide the entire
population of Israel
um and they're not you know they're not
necessarily genocidal people it's it's
uh it's that the the the the the the
narrative that
um pervades the Arab world about that
conflict
um
it there's two sides of the coin the the
the the hatred of what Israel is doing
and what they do whatever is tied
directly to deep empathy
for for the Palestinians and what
they're going through what they believe
they're going through
um uh and so you know you look at any
War where there's a huge you know you
know you have to you know and often
dehumanize the enemy during a war um and
that's why you call this propaganda it's
very common thing to do
um and usually that's going to be tied
with uh empathy for our people right
it's it's so these emotions go very
close together so oxytocin I'm not I
don't know the science of that but I'm
sure that's a similar concept here
um and
um and and I think that that when you're
when you're thinking with this kind of
primitive mind when I think we get
ourselves into trouble we're not being
wise a Telltale sign is that we have a
ton of empathy selectively like we have
so much empathy for people we consider
to be in our in-group and that doesn't
mean necessarily with the look like us
right it's it's people that we consider
you know uh sometimes there's racial or
ethnic or the are the core tribes right
so then yes as people look like you in
the US it's not like that at all it's
political tribe so
um it's it's people who who I think are
on uh in the good in the good side of
the the political divide
there's just endless excuses for
anything they do wrong I apologize you
know apology or or you know you could
say genuine empathy understanding
looking at the context and then as soon
as it's the other side
um all that goes out the window and just
bigotry just rank bigotry that is uh you
know no one feels no one thinks they're
being a bigot when they're being a bigot
right it's it's it's always you know
there's you always have to look at that
sneaky bigotry that's going to be
happening is always the kind that
doesn't get seen as big a tree like
um everyone knows that saying racial
slurs is bigotry right now and which is
why it doesn't happen very often
um but talking you know saying most
awful stereotyping you know mocking
dehumanizing stereotypes of
conservatives or of of you know woke
people or whatever
um that is so common because no one's
recognizing it as bigotry
um so that is to me it's selective
empathy it's it and and it's just like
you know you can't Okay so
someone is for free speech
um truly for it they they is
specifically tested by how much are you
for the free speech of
people you hate saying things you hate
right if you don't think they should
have free speech you are against Free
Speech everyone is for free speech of
people that agree with them and I would
say the same thing whether you're
actually an empathetic person and
whether empathy is a true principle of
yours uh is entirely determined by
whether you apply it universally or
selectively if you everyone applies
empathy to their in-group so anyway yeah
yeah no it's it's a very good point and
I guess my follow-up question is go look
I think everybody at this point knows
social media is bad for you no one goes
on Instagram comes off half an hour
later and go now that was half an hour
well spent job done
so at what point does the individual
have to take responsibility not only for
their attitudes but also for their
behavior yes you're getting hacked yes
certain behaviors are getting how should
I should how should I put it encouraged
but you've got responsibility as well
so I might I'm not sure I would quite
phrase it as
social media is purely bad and therefore
the the best thing to do is to remove
ourselves like like you know like soda
and candy and cigarettes right these are
uh these should be done in moderation if
you do it too much of those it's 100
officially bad there's no there's no
other way around it
um social media I think it's early in
this game and I think that we will look
back up first first of all there's just
an element of it's not going anywhere
right there's no way you're going to
take that back it is a part of the world
and it's not going anywhere so you know
that gets me thinking okay you know
given that we're not gonna all get off
what can we do but I I do think that
people in the future will look back at
today at least I this is a possible
possible prediction people will look
back and say that oh my God this was
like the it was the Wild West it was
just
it was it was like uh it was like
McCarthy's you know we look at
McCarthyism you know the Red Scare or
you know farther back stuff like the
Salem witch trials and we're like
sometimes humans just go nuts for a
while collectively and I think we would
look back upon this era and just be like
oh it was like it was it was clown town
a little bit
um and I think that
um my hope is that is that we we look
back and we're like no it wasn't that
social because first of all you know you
said you know if you go on for a half
hour or you never feel I'm not sure
that's true for me I I I agree honestly
you know I I have a lot of I and and I I
have a lot of friends on Twitter and I I
kind of I I love interacting with my
readers on Twitter and um you know Grant
when I post about politics I'm gonna get
more it's going to be more
frustrating it's going to maybe trigger
that that primitive mind
um but I think there's such a there's
there there's I think it's a lot like
life there's a really good side here
there's a there's there's a bad side
here now with social media it's easier
for the bad side to take over because we
don't see the people so we quickly can
dehumanize it brings out the worst and
it also brings a lot of people
who might be the you know the in
the in the company whoever knows so they
get marginalized or they get fired that
it it really elevates and makes
them front and center so there's a lot
of problems but I I feel like we're very
early and I'm My Hope Is that in 10 or
15 years we just between actual
algorithmic structural changes
and cultural changes where it becomes
really uncool to publicly shame on
social media becomes really an ad
hominem attack it just makes you seem
like a to everyone and then we'll
stop doing because everyone ultimately
wants to be cool they want to be part of
the so part of the reason things have
gotten so bad is that for a while maybe
still now a bit a little less so it's
been cool to to be you know outraged in
a really tribal kind of dehumanizing
publicly shaming way on something like
Twitter it's been like that's what gets
you like and I feel like we are I hope
growing out of that quickly and some
kind of etiquette will come back that we
have in the real world
and Tim I agree with you you know I
really enjoyed Twitter I not all the
time sometimes you'll laugh but most of
the time I have a great time I interact
with friends I make friends that I never
would have had I interact with people
who read my stuff or watch our content
and it's fun and it's great but as a
society we've acknowledged some of the
impacts that social media is having and
then it loops with the real world as we
talked about uh obviously Elon Musk a
guy you've interviewed a number of times
and whose companies you've looked at in
depth not Twitter per se but others he
recently spent a hell of a lot of money
44 billion dollars acquiring Twitter and
he's now playing around with it making
changes he's rebranding it he's paying
creators uh a share of the ad Revenue
he's got a big Vision do you have a
sense of the broad Vision that Elon has
for a platform like Twitter which he now
calls X and are you optimistic that he's
going to make positive changes with that
I mean
what I'll say about it is like the thing
I just said which is that I have this
hope
that if I go in a time machine to 2040
2035 even 2030
I get out of the time machine and social
media is just totally different and
better
now
that happens through changes
um and
um
it's very easy for companies that have
been around a long time
to just stop making changes I mean look
at look at the difference between you
know Apple in in the late Steve Jobs
years
um when they were just just enter an
industry like a bull in a china shop and
just do stuff and and they'll they'll
put out a thing and then they don't like
it they take it back and they'll they
were just very
um kind of like raw creativity
um and of course that changed the world
and now they've gotten into comfortable
incremental changes which like you know
I mean if I were Tim Cook I'd probably
do the same thing because it's great
money maker and what you know why mess
with it but
um
so I think that a lot of the social
media companies have gotten there where
they're just kind of stuck with they're
stuck in their own legacy stuck in their
own baggage it's hard to make changes
it's unpopular there's a lot of exist so
that's all to say that I totally welcome
a complete Outsider to come in and just
start just start getting getting their
hands dirty and let's try this and let's
experiment with a whole new model let's
see if this thing can make more money
and then you know let's mess with the
algorithm and now it's gonna make a lot
of people angry and and even myself
there's been times when I'm like oh this
out this new algorithm is like screwing
over my traffic you know it's not like I
I've been always happy and neither will
everyone right
but is a taking a step back I'm I'm very
happy with this storyline I love it I
think
just keep doing it keep making changes
trying things uh and and not settling if
something's you know it part of the
important thing is that when you put
through a change if you're doing that if
you're in that mode where you're getting
things dirty you know you're gonna make
a lot of mistakes you're gonna do things
that okay we did it quickly it wasn't
that's fine so it's fine as long as you
have no
um uh you you you you have uh you have
no problem just saying oh we were wrong
let's try this new thing right no so
it's it's there's different speeds you
can go some people might have taken a
more measured approach and you know and
and and done more focus groups and tried
beta tests that's not Elon style it
never has been it never has been you
know he he jumped into you know into
into cars into rockets and just started
making stuff and blew up a bunch of
rockets and you know and so some people
like that style some people don't and
for whatever you know for better or
worse that is his style it's obviously
served him a lot in the past I don't
know what's gonna happen but I do feel
like when the people who are really
criticizing like
now X and like a lot of these changes I
think it's not that I think they're
necessarily wrong about every criticism
I think it's that take a step back and
just realize that you are seeing of the
very few first few months of a bigger
story here and again the bigger question
is in five years you get out of that
time machine do you think that X is now
a very good social media company like
something that has led a lot of other
companies that's done a lot that's done
a lot of new things
or um do you see that and say I wish old
Twitter was back this is worse I don't
know but that's the question to be
asking not whether every little micro
change you're seeing now or every fumble
along along the way is is good or bad
people have a lot of strong opinions and
my that's I'm saying this more with
humility like I don't have a strong
opinion either way I'm very happy
someone someone who's very smart who has
a great track record is in their raw
experimenting that I think is great um
and then as far as how it'll go I don't
know but but the point is
I'll take change with the uncertainty of
whether that change will ultimately be
better or worse over the alternative
which is inertia stagnation with a model
that we all know is is not so great it
was 1.0 version of all this and we
didn't get it right point out agreed and
people like us who get a lot of
Impressions on Twitter are now getting
the paycheck out of there so I I've
definitely got no problem with that I
suppose the question I was asking you as
well Tim is
um Elon clearly overpaid for this
company at least I think he himself said
this
um and usually people do that when
there's a mission purpose to what
they're doing right he's buying the
company Because he believes it has a
material impact on the world the longer
lines of what we've been discussing for
the first part of this interview what
does Elon want what is he trying to do
and I don't just mean with Twitter or X
specifically I just mean more broadly
what is his vision for for what he's
doing
well okay so to be clear I haven't I've
talked to him about his other companies
thoroughly in the past um I haven't had
a chance to talk to him about X this uh
X so far so I all I can do is guess
based on what I've heard him say
publicly which is that he wants to a he
cares a lot about social media because
he thinks it's important he thinks that
and as and I agree with that you know
some people saying why is this guy
wasting his time on Twitter and software
instead of you know being out in the
world and like I see what they're saying
but I don't I don't agree I mean if this
is kind of the Public Square or it's a
kind of a the way that the human brain
is you know the collective brain is is
doing a lot of its thinking that is
really important and is important for
every other part of society
um and it's not great we all know it
needs changes so I think it's a worthy
Mission
um and I think he thinks it's obviously
a worthy Mission he also loves Twitter
you know he's someone who uses it a lot
and I think he cares about it and I
think he thinks he's thinking this is I
can get in there and and make this
better so uh and then and then he what
he said about his big mission is you
know he looks at WeChat in China and he
thinks you know there should be more of
an everything app an app that is really
something that you know almost everyone
needs and uses and that it's at this
kind of a hole in Western societies
where that app is in China and that you
know he has uh you know he bought the
name x.com years ago and I think he's
always had visions of what it could have
become um with you know with what and
what ended up you know kind of turning
into the the right turn into PayPal
there um but I think he has a bigger
Vision with X that never quite got done
and so he's thinking about you know that
Vision Plus
um you know I'm uh uh improving social
media plus making
um an app that can
um be something new like and something
that Americans it's hard for probably
Americans to even understand what an
everything app means because we don't
have one so and I I truly don't I don't
really get how WeChat Works um but I
think that he's thinking we could use
something like that over here and and
this is and you know he has said before
he's tweeted something like
um someone said why not why not leave
Twitter alone and just start x.com and
he said he he could have done that but
he thinks that uh starting with Twitter
is a is a multi-year head start on that
project
Tim it seems to me that
um Elon Musk has is a very disruptive
Force
do you think that's his superpower the
fact that he's prepared to come in to
disrupt to challenge the status quo to
make changes some of them which don't
work some of them which enrage people
and some of them which do
yeah I mean I wrote about this in um in
the series I did on him you know I I
wrote about SpaceX and Tesla and then
for that last post I said
okay so that's what he's doing but how
about why is this dude able to do what
he does right what's the secret sauce
and that's you know the answer I came to
and this is partially his own words is
that
um he's he's he Reasons from first
principles he likes that term and once I
started to understand you know what does
that really mean
um and you know it's one it's one of the
two major ways to reason you know
reasoning from first principles it's a
physics term it means you you just you
you ignore all the noise you ignore all
the conventional wisdom and the
assumptions and your own previous dogma
and everything else and you just look at
the facts you look at you know how much
the parts of the rocket weigh and the
force of gravity uh and the wind
resistance and you use that to say Can a
lock a rocket be landed can you can you
launch a rocket and then land it
and his answer to that question was yes
so he did it now there's a whole other
kind of reasoning reasoning by analogy
which is when instead of kind of
reasoning from first principles is
creating uh conclusion from scratch
based on first principles core kind of
axioms and and facts
reasonably by analogy is taking one of
the many existing conclusions or dogmas
out there and basically photocopying it
into your own head as what you believe
is true so these to use the rocket
example again what most people like Elon
would have done in that situation is say
if you could land a rocket the Soviet
Union and NASA would have done it a long
time ago they have every reason to do it
it saves a ton of money they had the
budget they had the scientists I coming
out of this and there's no way I must be
missing something people do this with
companies I I have this good idea for a
company but if it was such a good idea
someone else would have done it or you
know the
um uh just you know there's you can name
any major part of life
politics uh you know scientific you know
beliefs um
beliefs about the the world or you know
you know about the business World about
whatever
all of it is um or art you know what's
what makes a good art about it all of
that is almost always there's just this
big kind of tapestry of conventional
wisdom and most of us just say that's
reality and so if my independent
reasoning disagrees with the tapestry
conventional wisdom I must be wrong I
must be missing something
and that
is a humble normal way to think if
you're in 30 000 BC or you know 10 000
BC when when generation after generation
after generation things didn't change
very much so conventional wisdom was
wise it was the accumulation of a lot of
trial and error about the same repeated
kind of life
and so you were stupid you were naive if
you thought you were smarter than that
but now when the world changes so
quickly and Technology changes and every
five years the new possibilities that
are different than the old ones
conventional wisdom is actually very it
lags behind it's very foolish it's wrong
um and so it's so it's not off anymore
it's not always wrong and so it's
actually very rational to say I'm going
to trust my own reasoning when it
disagrees with conventional wisdom but
it were so wired not to do that so most
people they say I'm not going to build
the rocket because there's no way I'm
right NASA is wrong Elon doesn't think
that way to me his secret sauce is that
he is
um extremely good it just he just has
that he doesn't have this this
irrational thing that overrides his own
reasoning
um uh he's able to say I guess
I guess everyone's wrong I guess NASA I
guess NASA didn't do it right uh and
that just separates him right there I
mean you know there's a lot of things
that he's good at but that right there
makes him very unusual and so again with
Twitter
someone who reasons some first
principles they're going to experiment a
lot they're going to get something stuff
right they're gonna get some stuff wrong
but they're going to create change you
know Steve Jobs with the iPhone and use
that example too like
that you know they didn't just say well
what should our keyboard look like
because that's conventional wisdom that
there had to be a keyboard they just
said what should a mobile device be and
really reason from first principles and
came up with something totally different
and then turned out to disrupt the
entire industry so real disruption
whether it's artistic or entrepreneurial
or technological uh or intellectual it's
usually there's some real original
thinking going on from someone who has
the kind of that Epiphany that my
original reasoning is as good as
anything else out there
um and that and that I'm just as good as
a person to figure this out as as anyone
and it's but there's always a fine line
isn't there Tim between bravery and
recklessness and a lot of the time it's
if your idea works so if your idea Works
everyone goes yeah he was Brave whoa
whoa what a brave dude but if it doesn't
work it's like do you see what I mean so
it's it's a superpower and at the same
time it can be your greatest weakness
definitely it's a riskier way to live in
general but um another thing that Elon
points out is that
um a lot of times people are more afraid
than they should be they think you know
I I drew this in my post as a scale of
danger from one to ten and I said that
just say seven to ten is actually
dangerous you know either physically
dangerous or you're truly going to have
to you know not be able to feed your
kids or something
and then everything one to seven is you
know increasing risk but it's not
nothing that bad is going to happen if
it goes wrong and that I think that we
all hang in the one to three Zone
or you know maybe one to four Zone and
we think four five six and seven that
area is super dangerous and so we don't
do it
and the people that realize the danger
doesn't start till seven huge superpower
because they can go play in the five six
you know four five six seven areas and
change the world and do stuff and and
and they might fail and that what
they've realized is that it doesn't
really matter failure is okay uh Elon
has a quote about like
um he says I don't know I don't know why
more people don't start a company what's
the worst that happens you're not going
to starve you're not going to die of
exposure right like what's the worst
that's going to happen if the company
doesn't work out
um and that that not you know thinking
like that would make a lot more people
start companies
um and so many people sit there and they
dream about their company their whole
life they dream about writing that album
their whole life or whatever it is
writing that book and they never do it
because they they think that it is
their brain is incorrectly assessed that
as as real risk to fail at that maybe
it's a little bit of embarrassment and
the truth is most people are
self-absorbed not even thinking about
you it's a dumb reason not to do
something so again I can say this but I
feel it too we all have this kind of
irrational fear of of failure um and so
yes you could be more Reckless and I
think if you someone who's so reckless
they go up to the eight nine ten
um that's too far I mean maybe not for
everyone but like you have one life like
I don't think you should actually risk
your life very often I don't think you
should risk completely destroying your
financial situation you know to the
point where you again you have a family
and they can't go to school anymore
whatever it is
um I I think that that Reckless though a
lot of people call that four to seven
area Reckless when they see it and that
I think is wrong I think that's good
recklessness you people should get up
there and not worry about failing in
that area
that makes sense and I guess the thing
with someone like Elon and other people
who are who who have high wealth is that
you can risk tremendous amounts of money
without actually risking your family's
future or Comfort or security at all and
so you are able to take calculated risks
with really huge vast sums of money
without actually exposing yourself to
any true risk of the kind that you're
talking about so you're probably never
in the seven to ten range at all with
with you know with the example of what
he's doing with X if that that company
goes to Value zero he's still going to
be okay but there's also another huge
thing that we think is risky is
reputational risk yes yes so so so so so
many people would say I'm not gonna go
buy X because if that doesn't go well
I'll be made fun of it'll be disgraced
I'll be mocked people won't think you
know it'll tarnish my reputation and
blah blah blah and Elon just doesn't
care he doesn't think like that uh he he
says something like he says he says
stuff like
um if if something's important and it
has a 10 chance of succeeding it's worth
trying if something's important enough
even if it's only 10 chance of
succeeding so
um uh you know it's that's one of those
things where
when our brain was wired 30 000 years
ago 50 000 years ago whatever for that
world
reputational risk was a big deal you
know if you're if you you're thought of
as you know uh uh you know someone you
can't be relied on and and on the on
hunting or in the battlefield or uh you
were you were um you know someone who
couldn't be trusted or someone who
everyone mocked
you you your social the social your
social standing was incredibly important
for so many real hard reasons like you
need to have food and you don't want to
get kicked out and you want to mate in
your life it just isn't true today right
but we still have that wiring that we
are so scared of rejection romantic
rejection we're so scared of being seen
like a failure of people talking about
us behind our back of people thinking
they're better than us of of of you know
people making fun
again if you step back what's the worst
that happens here are you gonna die
nothing that bad is actually going to
happen you're not even in the room when
the people are talking about you
you're not there you won't know what's
happening and again most people are
self-absorbed they're just not thinking
that much about you Elon is very central
people are thinking about him and again
it's so what right he's gonna be dead in
a few decades like who cares about that
go for like the mission that matters and
like if it fails and people make fun of
you but again it's easy to say it's hard
to do and that's why uh most people
don't do it
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and Tim they're probably people
listening to this who are getting
inspired and them thinking to themselves
you know what I've lived all my life
however long however old I am in the one
to three I want to live my life in the
four to seven what do I need to do how
do I live it
well I think first of all it's thinking
about what you truly want to do not that
you know not that what you've talked
yourself into that you want to do or the
way you want to be or
it's easy to you know we talk ourselves
into a a worse story that is safer so
that we feel better about not having
gone so if you're what do you you know
if you had a genie and you could just
wish for the kind of life you wanted or
the kind of change you wanted to make or
the kind of family you wanted whatever
it is
um
no don't be scared what is it what is
that you know I mean maybe you're not
going to get it all you probably won't
but like don't don't be scared to look
at it don't be like uh depressed to even
thinking about just look at it right and
then start to think about what now what
does it tell what is it why have I not
gone for that whatever it is why am I
not going for it and assess that because
that is so often
is that your brain mistakenly because
it's up in nut step five of risk and
your brain uh mistakenly
um is is is your your is treating that
like real danger it's it's incorrectly
delusionally irrationally treating that
like real danger when the fact is you're
actually the suffering you're having
from not doing the thing you want to do
is real and that is taking a toll on you
and you're taking that toll as a heavy
cost to avoid what is not actually risky
but seems risky to us like like failure
potential failure or embarrassment or
reputational damage or you know maybe
having some hard financial years
um
ask yourself
is that
are those things worse than the there
you have a you have a positive that's if
things go badly right there's maybe
those things happen
and maybe you you achieve your dreams
you get the thing you really want
as instead of saying because I don't
want to take the chance of the negative
outcome there I'm going to take a
hundred percent chance of kind of living
with uh yearning and a little bit of
sadness and a little bit of envy and
maybe a lot of those things and a little
bit of bitterness
and you know it's like that's real that
sucks that's human pain like you're
accepting a lot of pain to avoid the
other potential human pain but at least
there there's the upside of it so
you know it's always very personal
everyone for some people embarrassment
is way way way worse than pain than
um than Envy or
you know bitterness ever could be for
some I think for a lot of people
embarrassment seems so much worse than
it actually is when it happens or you
know whatever you know so I get
criticism rejection just seems so scary
to us because we think we're gonna tribe
a long time ago and then it happens and
Sky doesn't fall and then you're a
little stronger because now you don't
you're not scared of it as much in the
future it's so interesting that you make
that point because we're both when we
started this we're both stand-up
comedians and a lot of people would say
doing stand-up is one of their greatest
fears actually and that is it's so
liberating doing it because you know
particularly when you start out you're
by definition not very good so you you
have times when you tell a joke and no
one laughs and to most people that is
the scariest thing possible and
comedians even call it dying when you
don't do well at a gig we call it dying
but actually when it happens it's an
incredibly liberating because you
realize it's nowhere near as bad as you
thought
I had a friend who was a kind of amateur
comedian and actually one night went out
and bombed on purpose like was just just
to say this is the worst thing that can
happen
they got some booze with some silence
and he left he was like is that was that
was that so bad no it's not it's not a
big deal right
um and uh and and so you know sometimes
you have to
um you can't just tell yourself
something's like you have to show
yourself you have to actually do it and
then
um
and then uh it can you know standard
comedian you know anything are artistic
uh you know a movie you know somebody
wants to make movies they want to make
music they want to
um they want to write a book people are
so scared to write fiction especially
um including me by the way I love Drake
fiction but it's ah
um and uh and you know public speaking
of course you know people avoid whole
careers they avoid you know ambition
being ambitious at work because if they
get a promotion they're gonna have to
speak in public more you know I mean
um and and uh and so there's so many
examples like this and in each case uh
your brain is not being very wise it's
actually it's actually like
um it's it's like you know it's like a
little kid it's like hiding under a
blanket because I think there's a
monster there it's not much wiser than
that and then you know you get older and
you say oh that it's cute of course kids
think there's March that are scared of
the dark
um it's not actually but then we do this
in our own way human adults do the same
exact thing
they do indeed and it seems to me one of
the great tragedies of our age Tim is
that we don't achieve the things that we
want we don't seek the lives that we
desire because
we're not used to experiencing
discomfort
discomfort feels a lot worse than it
actually is because we've inoculated
ourselves against it by avoiding
uncomfortable situations all the time
there's a great line in my favorite TV
show the British office
um
I'm so glad that you said that there's
so many Americans I know who say it's
the American office and they should all
burn in hell for that sorry thank you
it's I like the American office but it's
a show but it's another thing
it's another good show it is the UK
office is the best show ever made in
history I completely agree whenever you
want to come back on the show you're
more than welcome to okay so there's a
line where Tim who's a great character
he's kind of the relatable the relatable
character he says
you know he has this he he he hates his
life he hates his job he knows he should
be doing something different than
selling paper
and he's you know he's a he's a clever
guy he could do a lot in the world and
he you know he's building up courage and
saying yep I'm gonna quit and he kind of
does and then you know that that fear
that irrational fear kicks in and
suddenly he's back at the job and the
the you know the the mockumentary crew
asks him why and he says well you know
if you look at life like uh rolling a
dice then my situation now as it stands
yeah it may only be a three
if I jack that in now go for something
bigger and better yeah I could easily
roll a six no problem I could roll a six
I could also roll a one
Okay so
I think sometimes just leave the dice
alone
you know and it's again it's so
depressing right but so many of us think
that way so many of us think that way
where uh like you said the avoidance of
discomfort we will take
you know if you're actually truly
comfortable
that's fine I don't think people should
feel like oh that's not enough but what
does comfort mean Comfort isn't just
that you have the mean you know
financial means and
um that things are kind of easy it also
means you're comfortable in your brain
you feel good about life you feel good
about the world you wake up in the
morning and you like where you are right
that's real Comfort okay I think that's
great a lot of people they what they're
thinking of as comfort and avoiding
discomfort when they're actually in a
tremendous amount of discomfort already
because they don't feel like they're
living the right kind of life
um so again it's it's always assessing
like people don't like to think people
ignore this Factor when they're thinking
about the oh you know that this change
they could make they forget they're not
factoring in the cost that they're
experiencing every day right now uh by
not doing the thing and and by the way
it's not just for you it's not just a
selfish narcissistic discussion to be
having it's
you know if you're if you go out and do
something that you know you really want
to do the world is better off if you do
it you know you're you're depriving the
world of your gift if you're not doing
that or you know likewise if you're not
in the best relationship and so many
people aren't
um you can stay in it forever because
nothing seems scarier to our primitive
brains than going off on our own and
what if I don't find someone and oh
everyone's going to talk about my
divorce or my breakup and that it's
going to be conflict and so it'll just
stay in it forever meanwhile like you're
not doing that person any favors or
anyone you know when you hang out with
other people you depress people you know
when you're not a great kid you are
doing so much more for the world if you
go out and get yourself into a better
kind of relationship um you're you're
it's better for your family it's better
for your friends it's better for that
person and for the your ex as well
there's such a good point you make Tim
because one of the things I think when
people talk about being comfortable is
we we I mean it's not quite living in
the moment but we live sort of without
looking into the future enough to see
that if you play the movie Forward of
where you are and realize that this is
going to be the rest of your life how
uncomfortable does that make you if
you're not on the right path and I think
not enough of us do that uh in order to
actually jolt ourselves into action
about pursuing our dreams or going for
whatever it is that we're going to go
for I find that a very useful way of
checking whether I'm doing the right
thing is going if I carry on down this
path for the next 5 10 15 years is that
really how I want my life to look like
at that point and if I if it isn't it's
time to change something
I I um you know it reminded me of this
visual that I like to use
um and it's basically
um if you think about the past
when we think about our pasts we often
see there's kind of a life path that you
could trace and it's and it's led to
this moment so it's like kind of a
wiggly line from birth to here but we
also implicitly often see are all these
Branch offs that didn't happen right
these different lines
um that you know I I should have gone
and you know I I should have moved to
that City when I was younger I should
have seen my parents more I should have
done this whatever so many different
regrets regrets and you know sometimes
we're happy we didn't take those paths
and we like our path in certain ways and
then other times you know we say ah you
know I should have whatever
but the implicit idea when we think
about all these Branch offices that we
had agency in the past we could have had
those paths they were open there to us
but we didn't take them
and then that feeling of agency when we
think about the future so often is gone
so we think that now though I'm on this
path and it's just a straight it's a
path that you know I'm on it I'm on the
yellow brick road and here I am and
that's it
and actually uh in 20 years you look
back to today and you'll see all the
same Branch outs that you could have and
didn't do and they're all still open to
you right now because those are in the
future and you so you actually don't
have a single path you have a web in
front of you a big web and they're all
open to you right now and so there's a
kind of a double delusion going on I
feel like we think that we have we had
agency in the past but we don't anymore
we also have this feeling that we have
infinite time I like to think like you
know I went to both Barbie and
Oppenheimer it was like two movies in a
year I usually go to like maybe a movie
a year right in the theater but I love
it and in my head I'm like oh I'm gonna
go to hundreds thousands more movies in
the theater if I stay at this rate I
don't know I'll go to 40 30 40 more well
like that's a tiny number there's so
many things like this when you actually
think about it you realize time is quite
finite and so the combo of thinking that
we have unlimited time ahead
um and that we also don't have agency is
just a perfect recipe for complacency
it's like we don't change anything
because we don't think we can and we
also think it's okay because I'll later
I'll do all those things anyway
yeah and I would say our society
exacerbates that type of behavior in
people because we don't talk about our
own mortality we don't talk about the
fact that this is finite we don't talk
about the fact that there is going to
come a day a moment when we die we're
just like no no no no no I don't want to
talk about it well yeah then you're
going to live a life of complacency
because you you're not going to realize
you have a finite amount of time to do
the stuff that you want and need to do
yeah and by the way it's not even just
when you die like my grandmother was 97
and still going strong mentally but
she's blind and cannot go anywhere
basically and so
um well before you know uh the day she
actually dies she stopped being able to
do most of the things she loves right
and that that can happen a lot earlier
people can start
um declining in different ways you know
10 15 you know years before that so it's
super depressing but on the other hand
it's real and so
um what's what's what's the the much
more depressing is is because you don't
want to think about that like you said
you actually live in a very irrationally
complacent way that's why I like to like
do stuff like show how many weeks you
have left in a chart because it's like
holy but also it's like okay
let's go because
um you know it's like if that's real uh
it's like it makes it more real to talk
about it than uh you know denial is not
helping anything
Tim uh before we head on over to locals
where we'll ask you questions from our
supporters uh we always end up with the
same question but I should just say what
a positive uplifting episode this has
been you're gonna die or become disabled
very soon so hurry up and get on with it
I think is the message uh on that happen
you know Tim what is the one thing that
we're not talking about as a society
that we should be feel free to talk
about the British office again but no I
joke
yes that uh
but actually I would say my answer here
is extremely related to what we were
just talking about which is we should be
talking about longevity and Longevity
science
um I was just at a like a little great
Gathering recently where there were so
many of top people in life extension and
you know Health extension and and
um and there's so many fascinating
amazing developments happening
um and
like that's you know the the crazy thing
about the time we live in is like
technology is moving quickly enough
where there's a chance you know you'd
get in again time machine go 30 40 years
forward and get out and like you'd be as
shocked by the world you see as someone
from the 1700s would be coming to today
because the time you know Tech moves
faster as you go along
and in a world that's that shocking to
us what might come along with it is oh
people don't die involuntarily anymore
people die when they're ready you know
people you know most people don't want
to live forever but they they choose and
you you you
um we can refresh the human body we can
reverse age and we can stop aging
um it sounds sign it sounds sci-fi and
and magical it's not this what is the
body it's just a bunch of atoms if we
start to learn how to work with those
atoms and do stuff you can do anything
uh and so you talk to some of these
people who are working in these areas
and look we're far away we have a lot to
do but things can move really quickly
you know exponential progress is intense
and so I would say there's a good chance
that a lot of people maybe our age or
especially younger people could
legitimately live like uh to an age that
would shock most of us and you know you
could say oh well you know that's saying
no one's done that before you know
um uh you know you know we can't seem to
break through this hundred barrier
um and it's like yeah well also No One
Flew airplanes before people started you
know it's like at some point some
dramatic thing changes and this seems to
be one that's kind of on the cusp of
potentially having changes into me
the reason this doesn't get enough
attention is because
um it's it's it has this bad rep for
some crazy reason where people are gone
with narcissistic uh the billionaires
want to live forever it's like first of
all
then you should call anyone fighting
cancer narcissistics what are they
trying to do they're trying to fight
against this this force of nature that's
trying to end their lives and they're
fighting we say great they're Brave
they're heroic which they are
and then as soon as someone says well
now let's fight against all those things
so we can try to extend expand the human
lifespan they say oh narcissists it
doesn't make any sense uh it's the
Stockholm syndrome we have thing we have
with death it's like Nick bostrom's
famous you know tale of the Dragon Fable
of the Dragon I recommend anyone read it
we have this circumcision we think death
is a lot of man don't try to you know
anyone who tries to push against that
they're full and they're narcissist so I
think that's all very Incorrect and I
think that that's part of the reason
that more people aren't working in this
area we should all be talking about it
this depressing thing that we just
talked about actually can be changed
like it really can you can have a lot
more healthy long ears if we can get
funding and attention and smart brains
into these industries
all right so you've just amended the
takeaway from this episode to take away
from the episode is you're gonna die or
become disabled so get on with it
however a moment may be coming in the
future when you're not gonna die or
become disabled so grab that bag of
Doritos stick the office on have a good
time unless you're over 50 in which case
you're screwed yeah exactly uh Tim uh
and everybody watching head on over with
us to locals where we ask some of your
questions and continue the conversation
my procrastination is so bad that it is
destroying my potential to do something
truly meaningful with my life how do I
conquer this fun monkey inverter commas
hanging from my neck
[Music]